So when talking about the level of
assurance that we have in the system and
we said, well, we can do testing.
You can do formal verification.
So let's talk about why that is harder,
some of the challenges that we may
face when we're trying to do that.
Well, when you're doing tests,
you have to then rate the right
set of tests to your test cases.
Test cases are supposed to show
the existence of a problem.
If you don't have a good
set of these test cases,
then a problem that you may
have may go undiscovered.
In other words you want to
have good code coverage.
You won't execute the code that we have
in the software system and the kind of
execution paths we may be able to take
when the system is actually deployed.
The problem with this is that there
could be a very large impact on
exponential number of different
executions that are possible.
And these different execution paths
we're talking about could change when we
have different execution environments.
So we talked about
the other kind of testing,
which is the penetration testing, okay.
So that is the adversary actually or
somebody else trying to find one way.
Here when we're doing
testing as a good guide,
we have to make sure that every possible
execution path we know that is good.
So you have the burden of showing that
no matter how the system executes,
things will not go wrong.
If you're doing Pen testing,
the problem is different.
You're not concerned about
every possible execution path.
You're actually concerned about some
execution path where a problem shows up,
some vulnerability you discover
that can be exploited.
One way we do that is if ethical,
hopefully, hackers,
they attempt to defeat the security
measures that we have in place.
If they're successful that means
that we have a problem with
the security measures that
we use in our system, okay?
If they can't find any, that doesn't
mean that somebody else can't find them
two weeks from today, but if they
can defeat the security measures,
then we know that we have a problem.
Keep in mind that,
even with pen testing, as in testing,
we only talking about showing the
existence of a problem that is there.
That a problem exists.
We can never demonstrate
the absence of a problem.
And that is formal verification.
Formal verification is essentially
the mathematical specification of what
the program is supposed to do, and
what security assertions have to hold,
what security properties have to hold.
And it's a proof, and the proof is about
the correct behavior of the program or
any executions that
the program may go through.
Through.
So, how can we do this?
Well, there are automated
theorem proving techniques,
things like model checking and all.
What they typically do is,
at our program or code that we have,
we'll have a bunch of state variables
with some initial assignment or values.
And program instructions or
statements or
the code that we have actually
change these state variables.
Depending on what the instruction or
the statement is,
it's maybe assigning new variables or
altering, or computing and
things like that, whatever it is doing.
But the state changes and
then we have some boolean predicates.
The correctness is sort of captured
in predicates that hold on the state
variables that we have.
And so essentially, model checking or
theorem proving, basically is saying
that certain security assertion we have
is going to hold as the program executes
or as the state variables change,
due to the execution of the program.
The assertions remain true.
Okay, if you can show that for
everything that the program does
of course, all of its statements,
starting in some initial state.
That is a proof of correctness, or
formal verification that whatever
that we wanted actually holds.
Well the problem is that model checking,
the same sort of difficulty we had with
testing is that the state
space can actually explode.
And worst case complexity is,again,
exponential.
However, there are strides being
made in this field, Verification.
The problem that we have with it is
would it scale to really large systems.
And your operating system, of course,
is one of those large systems.
It doesn't quite scale
to that size system,
but as I said, strides are being made.
We can check where these
kind of properties, and
this kind of work actually.
So the model checking pioneers won the
highest award that computer science has,
the Turing Award, in particular in 2007.
Because of the importance or impact this
kind of work could have in, not just
building or writing software that
implements the functionality we desire,
but also implements the security
requirements that we want to have or
security properties that we
want to have in the system.